[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the inaugural
procession led by the chief marshal mr.
Karl and Mueller will now enter the
court the audience will please remain
seated
[Music]
yeah
ladies and gentlemen the 15th president
of the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology dr. Charles Marsteller vest
accompanied by chairman of the MIT
corporation dr. Paul Edward gray and led
by the chairman of the MIT faculty
professor Henry Don and Jacobi please
stand
[Music]
the corporation and the faculty of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
are now declared convened together with
this assembly to join in the
inauguration of Charles Marsh tiller
vest as 15 president of the Institute
please join professor Ellen Harris
associate provost for the Arts in
singing one verse of the national anthem
then please remain standing for the
invocation by Reverend Susan Thomas
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last me whose broad stripes
and bright stars despite the we watched
were so gallantly streaming
[Music]
I've been asked to invoke the presence
of God upon these proceedings it is my
duty and delight to do so although I
sometimes wonder whether this is what we
really want for one does so with fear
and trembling as well
nevertheless I invite you to join me in
prayer gracious God we boldly call upon
you this day to ask your guidance and
blessing upon Charles that he as
president of MIT might be your servant
for good as he shapes the future of this
Institute which in turn helps to shape
the future of your beleaguered bountiful
creation pour out upon him wisdom and
understanding counsel and might
knowledge and the fear of God in the
midst of his achievement give him a
humble heart and a resilient spirit that
the great responsibility he bears not
weigh too heavily upon him that he might
remember human frailty seeking and
granting forgiveness for mistakes or
wrongdoing as he already has done make
him soft as well as tough in the
tradition of his family nickname may he
know that we the MIT community of
students faculty staff and alumni like
the Detroit Tigers who sent him an
autographed baseball in honor of the
occasion wish him well
may he laugh frequently at himself
or with others for laughter and
lightness of heart is surely one of your
greatest and most redemptive gifts give
him wise and faithful friends bring him
counselors in justice and mercy
establish and strengthen the web of his
family especially blessing and upholding
his life's partner Becky as we look
toward the future and the critical next
decade for this planet may you indeed
guide MIT in its priorities I humbly yet
boldly ask that your hand move our hands
and minds in the work that we do we love
and desire that this earth be preserved
and even improved use us all as your
servants in these coming years to do
just that inaugurate your just and
loving purposes among us here today we
give thanks for past presidencies and
administration's of MIT especially today
for the conscientious leadership of
president Paul Gray and Priscilla gray
remain with them in their life and work
and keep them in your care all this we
ask trusting that you will hear our
fervent prayers this day and that you
already know what we most need amen
please be seated
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
dr. Frank HT Rhodes president of Cornell
University who will be giving remarks on
behalf of the academic community Frank
Rhodes a longtime friend and colleague
received his education as a geologist at
Birmingham in England following service
as a member of the faculty in the
administration of the University of
Michigan dr. Rhodes became president of
Cornell University in 1977 he is a
senior member in the major league of
university presidents and he possesses
as I know from personal experience
wisdom and a generous spirit which
complements his seniority it is a great
honor and privilege to have him with us
today as the Institute in barks on a new
decade under the leadership of a new
president Frank Rhodes mr. chairman
president vest
mrs. vest dr. Johnson dr. Wiesner dr.
Saxon members of the corporation and
members of the platform party
distinguished members of the faculty the
staff and student bodies honored
delegates from sister institutions
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen this is a great day not just
for MIT but for all of higher education
and all of us have felt a sense of pride
and expectation as we marched from 77
Massachusetts Avenue here to Killian
court to the fanfares
written by members of the MIT faculty
which welcomed in a new chapter in the
distinguished history of this great
institution gathering as we do to
celebrate Chuck vests inauguration as
MIT s15 to president
and formerly to hand to him the
responsibility for guiding MIT
positioning it to shape the future the
theme of this inaugural year I'm
privileged and happy to speak for all
institutions in congratulating MIT and
congratulating president vest on the
symbolic importance of today's
inauguration I also feel a special
kinship with Chuck vest he has been
close to Cornell in helping us over the
years as a member of our Advisory
Council for the College of Engineering
and I feel another kinship because he
and I is served for a time in the same
position there are different times at
the University of Michigan and I've
watched with admiration and pride his
growing success in a series of roles of
growing responsibility at that
University he brings to you as you have
already discovered outstanding
credentials not just as an engineer in
his chosen profession but also as a
teacher as a scholar and as an
administrator we can be confident that
with Chuck vest at the helm there are
great years ahead for MIT but the
university presidency at any institution
has always been amongst life's most
challenging professions boards of
trustees and members of the corporation
expect a degree of perfection in their
presidents that the English expect to
find only in their Butler's Newsweek
magazine a month ago had a lengthy
article on the university presidency and
the headline was wanted miracle-workers
Chuck vest may not be a miracle worker
but he is more than equal to the
formidable task that you offer him today
for the challenges facing universities
such as MIT have seldom been greater
than they are today
these have been recent months of
unprecedented concern and
criticism about all the nation's
research universities concerns about
cust both the cost of teaching and the
cost of research the perennial concerns
about increases in tuition and the more
recent concerns about indirect costs
concerns - about the quality of our
graduates with extensive argument about
the curriculum and about the competence
of the graduates of some institutions
concerned - about the integrity of our
scholarship and not least of all concern
about freedom of expression and
viewpoint on the campus no University in
no Institute can be immune to these
concerns and these criticisms for we
have an obligation not only to uphold
the integrity of our scholarship but
also to be responsible and prudent
stewards of the resources that are
entrusted to us academic freedom in the
end depends upon public trust and public
support and the price of public support
is public accountability since he
arrived on the campus last October
Chuck vest has shown himself to be more
than equal to addressing just those
concerns and more willing to deal with
controversial issues honestly and
straightforwardly
and equally important willing to think
carefully and deliberately about mi
t--'s mission and the longer-term
implications of that how to sharpen it
how to focus it how to preserve and
enhance its existing formidable
strengths and fashion those two new
emerging societal needs and
opportunities and that is just as it
should be fought it well on the problems
of the moment or of this year or next
year is simply to obscure the larger and
overwhelmingly positive role that
universities in general and MIT in
particular have contributed to our
national life and must continue to
contribute William Bennett when he was
Secretary of Education was once asked by
a seventh-grader how you tell a good
country from a bad one and he replied I
the gate test when the gates of a
country are open watch which way the
people run do they run into the country
or out of the country and that holds for
universities as well as countries it is
no coincidence that American
universities and not least MIT are
sought out by students from all over the
world and they're sought out not simply
as engines of basic research although
they have proven over and over again and
continue to prove how productive they
are in their particular regard
here at MIT one thinks of the first
chemical synthesis of penicillin or a
vitamin a the first complete synthesis
of a gene the development of modern
methods of food preservation and
development in a series of generations
of computer systems in countless ways
MIT has and does contribute to our
national well-being but the role of
research universities and not least the
private research universities such as
MIT extends far beyond those research
activities it is these universities that
have been particularly concerned with
the most gifted students something borne
out I note with satisfaction amongst MIT
s Nobel laureates which include eleven
current or former faculty members and
eleven alumni a fine and representative
balance and it has also been these same
research universities that have been
particularly devoted to quality and the
programs a professional and other study
that they represent particularly
concerned with innovation in those
programs it was here at MIT for example
a quarter century ago that the standard
for engineering education was
established and with Chuck vest
leadership and the commitment of the
faculty I imagine it may be a time that
is ripe for that to happen again
how much that surpasses even the great
dreams of William Barton Rogers who
hoped for so much for this remarkable
Institute when he founded it how much
that is a tribute to the leadership
which has gone before
and I note especially that of Paul Gray
and David Saxon of Jerry Wiesner and
Howard Johnson of Jay Stratton and so
many others and the commitment of many
people here in this court today whose
contributions over the years have set
mit apart as one of that small handful
of institutions of worldwide quality and
yet given the present climate of public
skepticism and of constrained resources
maintaining mi t--'s position will
require leadership of the highest order
and it is just that the Chuck vest is
superbly equipped to provide he brings
to MIT extraordinary skills in the
administrative sphere perception and
distinction as a scholar and teacher and
unusual grace and a rare ability and
total commitment together where the
resiliency and a sense of humor that
will serve him well and which I gather
have already been tested as on the first
day that he appeared in his office and
found that the whole wall was covered up
behind a large bulletin board covered
with clippings from the tick those are
qualities which will stand MIT well in
the years ahead I'd realize of course
that leaders are out of fashion today
and not least in the world of Education
they're either incompetent or they're
too smart
the few who aren't too weak are too
strong we're in favor of leadership but
we're against Authority I like John
Gardner's story about the wife who read
the card from a fortune-telling machine
that her husband had just got when he
dropped a penny and the weighing machine
and she took the card in her hand and
said you're a leader with a magnetic
personality strong character intelligent
witty attractive to the opposite sex and
then she turned the card over and added
and it has your wait wrong
- and yet leadership in the most
expensive sense is essential if our
research universities are to move beyond
the present period of criticism and
constraints and realize the potential
that they have to contribute to the
years ahead
that's more than management management
involves supervision of details
presiding over the established routine
leadership involves something more
seeing opportunities even in adversity
and kindling in others the passion of
their own commitment MIT is enormous ly
fortunate to have found just such a
leader in Chuck vest the responsibility
that you give to him and to Becky today
is awesome the office into which you
install him is lonely and what he most
needs now is your friendship and your
support not just in springtime but in
winter as well today he and Becky
dedicate their high professional skills
their experience their energy even the
affairs of their family to your service
and you have a reciprocal debt to him
because the strength of this institute
lies not solely in the skills of its
president or the distinction of its
faculty or the splendor and scope of its
buildings or the balance of its budget
or the magnitude of its endowment
important though all of those are nor
does it depend solely on the loyalty of
the alumni body or the quality of the
students or the devotion of the
corporation although these two are vital
the true strength of MIT derives rather
from the extent to which all members of
the community share common hopes and
common goals and are willing to commit
themselves to their achievement and so
today's ceremony is more than ceremony
it is a compact an agreement between you
and your new president and that compact
endorsed today links MIT to William
Barton Rogers and others who brought
this remarkable Institute into existence
130 years ago but it goes beyond that
because it links us to a larger
community of men and women who have
loved learning and defended it well it
bridges continents it crosses oceans it
spans the centuries stretching from
Bologna
and Paris and Oxford to Cambridge and
MIT here this morning and as you
reaffirm that larger partnership I'm
privileged to speak for all our sister
institutions in congratulating you on
your choice and in wishing the Institute
and Chuck vest good success may mi t--'s
distinguished past be but a prelude to
an even more glorious future which not
least in this inaugural year it is mi
t--'s privileged and special challenge
to shape thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
Longhi contains the song
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to introduce
Steven J Tapscott professor of
literature who will read a poem of
welcome
the poem of welcome ceremonious among
the glorious rhododendrons the faculty
progresses they walk in their medieval
costumes and for once their shoes are
shined under the stately engraved names
of white male scientists by their
presence the faculty embodies today's
welcome the poem of welcome walks among
them its shoes too are shined although
they are metaphorical shoes it walks
stately to the podium
its traditional tassel waggles ticklish
ly in its ears the poem of welcome asks
itself what in the world am I doing here
what does a poem have to do with power
or the transmission of power or the
ceremony of the occasion of transmission
Charles best seems like a decent man
look for a lyric poem that is very high
praise the faculty has gathered to thank
him to welcome and to warn him decent
people know how every welcome contains a
kind of gratitude and how every real
welcome is a kind of warning to both
parties and jeepers this is an occasion
before and behind the poem the faculty
assembles in welcome they wear their
gaudy costumes and legitimized the
occasion many are women others have
tenure how solemn they seem assembled I
am not entirely sure that I want to be a
note of welcome thinks the lyric poem to
itself I think I might prefer to be a
deconstructed politically correct lyric
of soaring beauty and searing cultural
analysis look I think I prefer to be a
poem for a hundred years forward with
tenure in the great anthologies of the
future I think I want to be a poem to
make strong adults weep and virgins
quiver and little children dance in the
meadows if there are Meadows in a
hundred years in the future maybe I want
to be a poem of elegy for meadows what
does a poem have to do with occasions of
power hmm thinks the poem well anyway
how can a lyric poem speak for the
diversity and polyvalence and generative
foment of a cadet contentious collective
like the
Institute and come to think about white
and come to think about it why does this
poem sound like it's written in prose
the poem is love welcome is on a bad
roll now it is winding it's welcome
disgracefully in front of everyone and
those composers they had it easy
processionals without irony without the
need for declamatory assertions welcome
they honked with their big trombones
here we are step off a big melodic line
some bass and a beat you can march too
but can a poem use a brass trombone no
it's not the same using words not like a
trombone the poem reimagines itself ode
with trombones welcome honk-honk to
Charles vest when when when when where
it's just not the same lacking brass
before and behind the poem by now the
faculty is getting a little restless
they scuff their shine shoes against the
temporary platform they gaze off towards
the Charles or back up towards the dome
from deep in the drooping sleeves of
their robes surreptitiously they bring
out peanut butter sandwiches they know
they knew they were in for a long one
furtively they pick off pieces of peanut
butter sandwich and slip them into their
mouths behind their hands their throats
are dry but they brought no drinks not
wanting to risk spills because they
because they are intellectuals and just
a little bored some set themselves
intricate challenges like how to pull
the wrapper off the Clark bar in your
pocket without making a single crackling
sound some have brought paperback books
which during the poem they slip open
only a crack deep in the fabric of their
robes and read politely pretending to
pay attention one leans back with eyes
closed
it would seem she is asleep but she is
not she is a mechanical engineer with
mathematical training like Charles vest
the poem remembers what Bertrand Russell
said how from the outside it is
impossible to tell the difference
between a mathematician thinking and a
mathematician sleeping and so the poem
understands in what way this behavior is
the behavior of authentic welcome
because this is the faculty expressing
the fact of themselves under the rented
robes
and this after all is what they do they
work during this time - during this
occasions in their heads they're working
and here is the enacted shape of that
obsession the configurate passionate
solitude of learning to which they
welcome Charles vest as colleague and as
leader through the eyes in the back of
its head the poem of welcome looks back
and surveys the stage it looks forward
toward the faculty it sees among them
faces it recognizes because the poem is
a fiction it recognizes among the
faculty also like Holograms some
fictions who pass for faculty on
occasions like these the poem sees the
two figures humanist and engineer from
the great symbolic seal of the
Institute's you can recognize them the
humanists studies a text the engineer
carries a hammer to match his anvil
though the poem has always wondered
symbolically why they are both white men
and for that matter why anybody even an
engineer would love an anvil around with
him wherever he goes
and because the poems nature is to be
wholly symbolic it has always bothered
the poems symbolically that the two
figures stand there on the seal of the
Institute humanists and engineer and
turned their backs on one another who
thought that one up thanks to the poem
possibly the same designer who made that
poor engineer Lucky's anvil around today
highway today however they are sitting
beside one another using the anvil as a
footrest generously they pretend to pay
attention they are fictions but they are
true enough to the life here to be busy
even a little preoccupied the faculty is
gathered here to embody a welcome in
their preposterous accoutrements
therefore it is easy for the Magi to to
blend themselves among the faculty the
poem of welcome knows which one's the
Magi are but the poem isn't telling they
blend like Holograms better they should
be indistinguishable as they have chosen
or maybe the occasion has chosen them
generated them the mage eye themselves
which with its solemn and ritual energy
yes they are the same age I though not
on the same mission nobody here
seriously expects a college
administrator to resemble an
kind of Messiah they are figures of
speech in a speech of welcome that is
they are figures of welcome the poem of
welcome prefers to believe that the mage
I have come here voluntarily because
that is what they do since their
retirement they move forward or continue
venturing knowledge and the forwarding
faith of knowledge they weren't
necessarily Christians then or now but
they were the first scientists and part
poet and part administrator magician
astronomer mathematician awake or
thinking who arrived at a mystery by
means of equation by faith in their own
calculations which pulled them toward
the unknown the others the shepherds had
angels and I would bet that the Angels
had trumpets but that was another story
they believed in knowledge and in
mystery the Magi and in ritual
embodiments of welcome the poem of
welcome wanders after all if that is why
this poem sounds as if it is written in
prose because prose is the track of
forwarding momentum it does not turn as
traditional verse does it runs forward
and incorporates what it addresses
learning and becoming it the Magi shift
a little uncomfortably in their seats
they are a little embarrassed
they have been here a long time and the
seats are hard and they're not so young
anymore and they neglected to bring foam
cushions in the sleeves of their robes
but they brought their invisible gifts
their capacity for work they're awed
obsessiveness their purity of
concentration their love of teaching and
yes their contentiousness there
occasionally irritating naivete their
social conscience their ability to talk
on and on and on in the committee
meetings it is very easy for the Magi to
blend among the faculty and they do
merge into the spirits and body of the
faculty assembled to embody this
occasion from the outside you'd never
know who they are they have traveled a
long way through race and class and sex
figures of knowledge and a forward
motion of magic and equation and poetry
the poem of welcome is happy to see its
old friends though it doesn't give its
secret their secret away they will help
the poem to say welcome though they say
nothing
thus the poem speaks like the Magi in
inclusive Li and just as the poem speaks
for the faculty so here the faculty
stands for the Institute inclusively and
the poem says welcome the teaching staff
the office staff in the windows the
grounds the library the laboratory staff
kids in the daycare administration the
corporation the Arts Council God loved
them say welcome and are welcome because
this poem says so exercising the poems
utopian prerogative and so the poem says
what it came to say it says welcome it
says so in English and Spanish being
Veneto
it says so in Mandarin Japanese and
Korean Wong yang Cheng AI Wan youngja
Bonita it says so in Russian rush
neoprene and polish poet Anya it says so
in Yiddish and Arabic Shalom alaikum
assalam alaikum it says so in Kurdish
karien it says so in hillbilly howdy
it says so in Swahili caribou it says so
in Yoruba al kaba it says so in Ashanti
a Carrabba it says so in American sign
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my great pleasure to introduce
Charles Marsteller vest the 15th
president of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology this ceremony
culminates a process that began two
years ago when the corporation and
faculty committees on the presidency met
for the first time in a room overlooking
this perpetually sun-drenched Killian
Court there followed an intense
year-long effort during which the
faculty and trustees worked side by side
each meeting and a regular patchwork of
pinstripes with Harris tweeds our first
task was self education about MIT s
needs challenges and opportunities we
also learned about the staggering
dimensions of the president's role and
the complex arena in which he or she
must function for example I remember
Paul Gray contrasting a university
president with a corporate chief
executive when a CEO announces a
decision Paul said the staff generally
not acceptance and then get on with it
in a university the faculty inevitably
look you in the eye and ask why and you
better have a good answer because if
it's not the faculty it's the students
or alumni or parents or occasionally a
congressman from some Midwestern state
eventually our committees agreed that
all we needed was the composite clone of
Thomas Edison Marie Curie Winston
Churchill and Lee Iacocca with that
premise we did in fact identify a group
of people of extraordinary talent and
accomplishment from both inside and
outside MIT the greater challenge was
choosing among them
at the end of an illuminating indeed an
eventful process we put forward the name
of Charles vest with confidence and with
enthusiasm Chuck vest fits the template
of an MIT president his academic
credentials are impeccable active
teaching research and scholarship the
publication of a major textbook
initiatives with industry and government
though every bit the model professor
Chuck vest was clearly not one of those
academics described by our neighbor
henry rosovsky as those who carefully
cultivate a selection of disabling
traits so as to avoid administrative
chores instead chuck took on roles of
increasing leadership within his
institution the university of michigan
first as associate dean then Dean of
engineering and finally Provost a job
which made him responsible for the 17
schools and colleges of that great
public university and chuck has other
attributes not listed on the balance
sheet in Who's Who
but equally important in fitting the
template genuine openness personal
warmth and the ability both to listen
and to hear special concern for students
and young faculty a deep commitment to
excellence and a sense of humor robust
enough that it even permeates his
electronic mail above all is Chuck's
devotion to the fundamental principles
of the Academy principles deeply
engrained during a lifetime spent on
university campuses this collegiate
upbringing by the way parallels that of
Karl Taylor Compton another MIT
president who like Chuck took office as
a newcomer to the Institute as an
engineer Chuck knows that complex
problems do not succumb to simple
solutions nevertheless even in these
uncertain times his vision is like that
articulated nearly 50 years ago by
Vannevar Bush a vision of faith in the
application of science to
the needs and desires of mankind well
another pertinent piece of wisdom from
Vannevar bush is the following never
start a speech unless you have in mind
the sentence with which you are going to
conclude so here's mine
on behalf of the faculty and the entire
MIT community we welcome you chuck and
becky vest we thank you for accepting
this daunting responsibility and we
pledge our labor and support as you lead
us and this great institute forward and
now as chairman of the corporation of
the massachusetts institute of
technology and on behalf of that body
i shall proceed to induct into office
our 15th president dr. charles
Marsteller vest well professor Johnson
and professor Wiesner please bring dr.
vest forward
Charles Marsteller vest by the authority
of the corporation and with the
enthusiastic approval of the faculty the
alumni and alumnae the student body and
this distinguished assembly I present
into your keeping the charter of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and invest you with all the authority
privileges and responsibilities of the
office of President may you serve the
Institute and dignify its office of
president with all the skill wisdom and
dedication which our confidence Accords
to you and may your administration be
memorable dr. gray I accept this charter
as the symbol of office of the
presidency of this great institution I
do so with a full sense of the magnitude
of my responsibilities and I am deeply
grateful for your trust I pledge myself
to work unremittingly with the trustees
faculty students staff alumni and
alumnae for the greatest good of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
[Applause]
this is indeed a splendid moment as we
gather to celebrate a great institution
to renew our commitment to a set of
ideals to mark a passage and to set a
course for the future yet for me and my
family
it is also an intensely personal
experience and one that we are honored
to share a journey that began in a warm
family in a small town in West Virginia
has led to center stage in Killian Court
where my own path and that of the
Institute have come together in this
symbolic moment it is a profound
privilege to walk with four great and
gracious men Jay Stratton Howard Johnson
Jerry Wiesner
and Paul Gray your trust and guidance
give me great comfort and courage for
the task ahead on the banks of the
Charles River an institution has arisen
that is recognized throughout the world
for its unique contributions to our life
and times established 130 years ago this
spring MIT did not become yet another
comprehensive university nor did it
become simply an engineering school or a
polytechnic institute rather it became a
wellspring of scientific and
technological knowledge and practice and
a place where musical creativity thrives
its inventive and entrepreneurial
faculty generated a great economic
engine and they have created
revolutionary insights into the
structure of language the nature of
learning they have led the quest to
decipher the molecular to decipher the
molecular foundations of life they have
influenced the political and economic
policies of Nations mi t--'s engineers
and scientists made critical
contributions to our nation's security
when that was largely a military manner
and its graduates have given
architectural manifestation to
humankind's highest cultural and
artistic insights MIT has been home to
distinguished scholars from around the
world men and women who have stretched
the human mind and spirit above all it
has provided an intense and effective
education to generations of the
brightest young men and women that this
nation and the world have brought forth
now MIT prepares for the passing of the
20th century and the advent of the 21st
we seek form and substance appropriate
for these times even as we seek to shape
the future of our nation and world but
we enter more than a new temporal era we
stand at the dawn of a new global age
our lives are interwoven across national
boundaries in unprecedented ways
connected through our Earth's
environment whose stewardship we all
share through our economic and
production systems through instantly
shared information through universally
shared dreams these dreams include the
vision of a world in which the security
of Nations is defined by economic and
social dexterity rather than by military
might they include the vision of a
nation that has regained its sense of
social justice and it's truly the land
of opportunity for all MIT has played a
remarkable role at critical moments in
shaping our nation and our world we have
done so through individual creative
genius and through grand institutional
ventures like America itself
we've responded in a neuro ik and
innovative manner to sudden challenges
such as the onset of World War two or
the launching of Sputnik today we are
challenged once again on a grand scale
but this time by slow corrosive forces
rather than by sudden galvanizing events
by the erosion of our global environment
rather than by explosions at Pearl
Harbor by declines in scientific
literacy and industrial competitiveness
rather than by the launching of a
satellite this morning I would like to
share with you my view the challenges
that confront us and to offer a growing
vision of the opportunities they present
for the future of MIT there is a
remarkable image itched in the mind and
psyche of our generation we were the
first to view a shimmering seemly
seemingly peaceful planet Earth from the
depths of space still here below we know
that we inhabit a raucous global village
we are connected across time and space
as never before in human history many of
these connections have been made
possible by the advances in science and
technology
we must learn to deal with this
interdependence in new ways creating new
forms of organization incorporating new
points of view
let me give three examples first the
Earth's environment the fragile envelope
that bears witness to the degrading
effects of human activity it is no
longer possible if it ever was for
individuals or nations to think that the
way in which they treat their land air
and water has no bearing on their
neighbors nor is it possible for us to
work on each aspect of this damaged
environment as a separate problem
ironically many of the scientific and
technological advances that so enhance
human comfort and well-being advances in
transportation energy and agriculture
concurrently posed threats to our
biosphere this presents a challenge and
an opportunity for us here at MIT I
believe that we must marshal our
interests and capabilities to understand
these issues and to develop solutions
such an endeavor will require a new
generation of scientific computation for
atmospheric modeling new instrumentation
for monitoring environmental conditions
new modes of analysis and new
technologies to correct or avoid
problems beyond this we need to come
together in new ways from different
fields different organizations and
different countries to understand
only the physical but the cultural
economic and political forces that
affect the health of the natural world
the stage has been set at MIT by the
establishment of the Center for Global
Change science and by the new Council on
global environment only with this kind
of integrated approach drawing on
faculty from disparate fields can we
hope to meet the profound challenge
making and keeping our planet livable
another challenge and set of
opportunities in our increasingly
interdependent world lies in the realm
of electronic communication
instantaneous communication both verbal
and visual has reduced our planet to the
electronic global and global village
once envisioned by McLuhan knowledge has
become a capital asset at least as
important as physical resources bits of
information flowing through copper wires
optical fibers or satellite links have
become a new currency the currency of
the information marketplace increasingly
the commerce of this new marketplace
will be conducted along fiber optic
information superhighways that will
connect computers telephones
high-definition video systems and hybrid
technologies yet to be developed this
information infrastructure already
exists in rudimentary form MIT has the
opportunity to play a pivotal role in
bringing increased capabilities and
coherence to this system and in defining
the currency of the new information
marketplace in doing so we must not only
increase the power and ease of computing
and communications but we must do so in
ways that enhance our intellectual and
social capabilities that help us make
wiser decisions then that enable us to
bridge cultural and political barriers
here too we must invent new ways of
combining our talents across
disciplinary and institutional
boundaries in order to give form
substance and humanity to the dawning
Information Age
to this end I am pleased to announce the
establishment of the MIT information
infrastructure initiative a project that
will bring together eight different
organizations within MIT with the goal
of working with industrial partners to
develop a new very high frequency
entirely optical network and to
establish within our campus a working
model of the information marketplace my
third example derives from the
increasing political and economic
connections throughout the world that is
this with the MIT of the future be a
national or an international institution
what does it mean for MIT to be a
citizen of a world where common problems
or interests are often more powerful
than Geographic distances yet where
national differences exist the issue is
complex MIT is a national institution
but America is no longer isolated mit
was born as a manifestation of Yankee
ingenuity and know-how it has served as
a driving force for the creation and
improvement of American industry it is
funded to a very significant extent by
the American taxpayer and above all it
is centered on the education of many of
the brightest and most talented young
people in the United States MIT is of
and for America today however in order
to serve America well we must
participate in the broader global
community basic science has always
prided itself and being the prototype
for true international cooperation but
today this viewpoint and system are
being strained strained because of the
increasing economic value of university
generated knowledge and technological
concepts there are those who look at
this country's position on the economic
balance scales and call for greater
protection of our ideas especially those
having to do with science and technology
some look to this country's troubles in
the world marketplace and are quick to
blame our over
sees competitors others cast the issue
into the framework of pogo possums
famous saying we have met the enemy and
he is us and still others quickly
respond along the lines of Robert Reich
who asks who is us that is in this day
and age what defines an American
corporation clearly we must be concerned
with this nation's economic well-being
we must not however endanger the very
essence of our institution by retreating
into simplistic forms of techno nation
ilysm to draw boundaries around our
institution to close off the free
exchange of Education and ideas would be
antithetical to the concept of a great
university the list of nations that had
difficult historical moments closed
their universities to the outside world
is not one we would be proud to join
this does not mean that we could not on
occasion establish special programs
directed at the solution of national
problems however any such programs must
also fit one fundamental rule all
students once admitted to MIT must be
able to fully participate in our
educational and research programs
without regard to their citizenship in
my view a much more important concern of
MIT should be the establishment of
programs to ensure that our students are
educated in such a way is to prepare
them to lead full responsible lives as
world citizens it's time that we made
the matter of international context and
opportunity an integral part of an MIT
education
just as we develop new connections among
nations so too must we seek new
connections within our own the face of
America is changing significantly and
rapidly our society is increasingly
pluralistic get our connections across
racial ethnic and sometimes even gender
boundaries are frayed securing America's
promise for all remains a crucial goal
the nation's potential will not be fully
realized till all racial and ethnic
groups have full opportunity to realize
their own potential and in doing so to
contribute fully to the health and vigor
of our society mit has traditionally
educated engineers scientists and others
to develop technologies lead businesses
service professors researchers and
scholars to continue this leadership in
the era ahead we must better reflect the
changing face of America in our students
faculty and staff we can clearly see
such such changes in our undergraduate
population thanks to the leadership
commitment and concerted effort of many
here with us today among our graduate
students and their faculty however we
see far less evidence of this change as
yet we must double and redouble our
efforts to attract the brightest and
best from all races both women and men
not only to our undergraduate programs
but our graduate school and to our
faculty there are many social and
historical forces mitigating against
success in this endeavor
it will require renewed commitment on
the part of each of us to identify and
recruit these scholars once they are
here to do our part to see that they
attain their full potential as one step
we will begin implementing during the
coming weeks a program proposed by the
Equal Opportunity Committee to recruit
more women to our faculty we will
reaffirm and reinvigorate their policies
and programs for bringing more
underrepresented minority
members to our faculty as we succeed and
in order to succeed with these and other
efforts we must work to ensure that MIT
is a place that respects and celebrates
the diversity of our community just as
we celebrate learning about the physical
universe or the political or economic
worlds or the creative arts so must we
celebrate learning about and from each
other such change is rewarding but it is
seldom easy
during the years ahead we must refuse to
let the centrifugal forces of
intolerance and injustice pull us apart
we must be held together by respect for
the individual and by a commitment to
the values we hold in common just as we
as individuals are part of an inter
woven social fabric so too is MIT part
of an interdependent educational system
one that begins before kindergarten and
extends through postdoctoral studies
within this system America's colleges
and university stand as national
treasures but the strength of these
institutions and thus of our society is
imperiled imperiled by the state of our
primary and secondary schools and
imperiled by the declining interest and
ability among our young people to pursue
rigorous Advanced Studies particularly
in science and engineering these trends
must be reversed it is my firm belief
the National that national educational
strength is the essential prerequisite
for economic and social prosperity
education can move a nation the future
belongs to those who understand it at
all levels active and foreign
participation in our economy and our
democracy now requires an ability to
understand basic scientific and
technical concepts and yet American
popular culture pushes us in the
opposite direction we need no less than
a change in the culture of this country
a revolution and attitude about the
importance of education and in
particular scientific and mathematical
literacy until we as a nation wake up to
the fact that we must increase our
investment in the growth of human
capital that is people and ideas our
educational system will spiral downward
pulling our economy and our way of life
with it this is a danger of the first
magnitude and we must all work to
address it 30 years ago MIT played a key
role in launching a nationwide wave of
education reform and the sciences the
time has come again for us to place our
expertise and stature in the service of
a major national effort to rebuild the
strength of Science and Mathematics and
American schools
I believe that MIT not only can but must
draw on its special strengths to help
renew effective accessible education for
the young people of this country the
education that we most directly
influence however is the education of
our own students among them are people
whose passion is to engineer a better
world among them are people with a
particular concentrated brilliance among
them are profoundly creative people who
tread new and different pathways we are
gifted with some of the very brightest
young people of our nation and of the
world it is through these students that
MIT will have its greatest influence on
the world of the future in recent years
our faculty has been involved in
long-term review of its undergraduate
program the intensity of this review is
testimony to the fact that education and
particularly undergraduate education is
at the very core of MIT no one has been
more engaged in these matters over the
years than our engineering faculty
indeed the engineering curriculum of
this country was largely developed by
MIT faculty in the 1950s and 60s they
spearheaded the infusion of basic
science into engineering education and
practice
the results were astounding we produced
engineers who created a revolution in
computing and communication developed
vehicles to explore outer space and
started not only companies but entire
industries based on high technology
while this curriculum has been complete
continually refreshed its fundamental
approach and content remained
essentially unchanged for thirty years
the world in which engineering is
practiced on the other hand has changed
dramatically and rapidly take for
example the decline in the United States
ability to compete in the world
marketplace for manufactured goods the
reasons for this decline are complex but
a major issue has certainly been the
attitude of Industry and of universities
toward the design and manufacture of
consumer products we need to infuse
therefore our engineering students with
an increased respect for and enjoyment
of effective efficient and socially
responsive design and production today
we must prepare engineers who have the
self-discipline analytical skills and
problem-solving abilities so highly
valued in MIT graduates but who are also
prepared for the challenge of production
and leadership in the world marketplace
the next century this is but one of the
challenges to engineering education but
it is indicative of the concerns that
face our faculty as they design a
curriculum that will serve our students
well into the 21st century
they will do so in the setting of this
research university a setting in which
the unique blending of graduate
education undergraduate education and
research creates unparalleled
opportunities for learning and for
discovery a setting that keeps both our
education and our research
forward-looking and robust all do not
agree with this view many believe that
our mission has become distorted and
that education has been lost in the
desire and responsibility to excel in
research this is clearly a central issue
for MIT
it must be openly discussed in all
corners of the Institute this fall is an
event of the inaugural year we will hold
a major colloquium on the topic of
teaching and learning within the
research university
I intend this to be a no-holds-barred
debate that will illuminate our efforts
to shape the future of education at MIT
educational success at MIT depends above
all else on the commitment and
inventiveness of our faculty excellence
in undergraduate teaching must be
rewarded and encouraged to this end we
are establishing an endowed program to
recognize faculty members who have
profoundly influenced our students
through their sustained and significant
contributions to teaching and curriculum
development a select number of faculty
will be appointed as faculty fellows
each for a 10 year period and will
receive an annual scholars allowance
throughout their appointment
the first fellows will be appointed this
year and we expect their ranks to build
to at least 60 during this decade the
strength of an MIT education is its
depth and intensity our graduates value
above all else their self-discipline
analytical thinking skills and their
confidence to take on great challenges
today science and technology culture and
policy industry and government
production and communication are
interwoven as never before the nation
needs broadly educated young men and
women to be leaders of the next
generation an understanding of science
and technologies surely part of what
such leaders must possess similarly
those who practice science and
technology need an ever greater
understanding of the world in which they
will work and must be able to contribute
wisely to policies affecting the
development and uses of technology what
does this mean for education at MIT
surely it means that a careful balance
among the humanities arts and social
sciences on the one hand mathematics and
the physical on life
Sciences on the other but it means a
continuing look at our departmental
programs to ensure that in content and
approach they give our students the best
possible foundation for intellectual
growth and professional achievement our
campus should be a place in which
humanistic and artistic scholarship and
creation can flower in unique and
important new ways I further believe
that we at MIT have an unusual
opportunity for the humanities and
engineering to enrich each other while
the continuum from the humanities to the
night to the Natural Sciences has long
been recognized the continuum from the
humanities to engineering is less well
explored in general such exploration in
my view has been hindered by a
utilitarian view of the humanities and
social sciences on the part of many
engineering educators and by a lack of
appreciation of the intellectual content
of modern engineering by many humanists
an MIT education should enlarge an
individual's choices and so should
include a common experience in Science
and Mathematics a serious exploration of
the humanities arts and social sciences
and a continuing conversation among
these fields I believe that the creative
tension generated by these varying
interests and cultures can serve us well
as we continue to renew and to review
and renew our undergraduate programs we
have a common currency of excellence and
creativity regardless of field that will
enable us to develop new modes of
inquiry and teaching that will make the
most of the unique intellectual
community that is MIT we have a special
set of talents and focus that give MIT
its distinctive character by building on
our special strengths MIT will
contribute in rich and often unique ways
to the times and to the nation's needs
we should not expect to be all things to
all people one of the great strengths of
the American educational system is the
great variety of
public and private colleges and
universities this condition allows for
and indeed demands experimentation
variation cooperation and competition
the resulting synergy is the yeast that
keeps our system strong for decades the
American research universities have
served this nation exceedingly well from
virtually any perspective they have paid
enormous dividends in return for the
public's trust and investments dividends
in the form of educated leaders in
academia business and government but
Vance's in medical care and nutrition of
national security of new and revitalized
industries of increased understanding of
our physical social and natural worlds
but today the American public is calling
into question the value of our research
universities and no longer tends to view
Science and Technology is the foundation
of progress the public's attention is
caught not only by the debate over the
costs and quality of undergraduate
education but by the debate over the
costs and conduct of research the doubt
of the moment however must not be
allowed to weaken the basic concept of
the american university system one that
is universally recognized as being the
best in the world
this system is founded on a social
contract with the American public and
enhanced by partnerships with government
and industry we cannot keep our
flexibility our vigor our quality as a
nation or as naked as an academic
community by taking this partnership for
granted we need to rebuild trust in this
nation's research universities and its
scientific enterprise we must ensure
that the foundation of scientific
scholarly research is secure
what is this foundation Jacob Bronowski
stated it with deceptive simplicity when
he wrote the end of science is to
discover what is true about the world in
seeking scientific
truth ideas and hypotheses or debated
tested prove disproved revised build
upon or rejected this activity has
carried out by researchers in different
laboratories and different universities
indeed in different countries that is
what makes science indeed most
scholarship simultaneously an individual
and a communal activity and it is why we
have a new why we have usually been able
to rely on this system to detect and
correct error like all human endeavors
science is not and cannot be totally
free from error or even occasional abuse
and so it rests upon us the scientists
and scholars to do a better job of
strengthening continually renewing and
transmitting our system of values
great teachers in part and stimulate the
passion excitement and beauty of
intellectual endeavor but it is equally
important that we impart and stimulate
the meaning of the necessity of and the
passion for the pursuit of truth with
integrity and ethical rigor but whatever
we say ethical lessons will be taught
primarily by the ways in which we
undertake our own scholarly activities
these lessons will also be conveyed by
the ways in which our institutions
handle problems if they do arise how we
deal with alleged misconduct will also
affect the strength of society's
confidence in regard for our
universities and colleges and for the
enterprise of science we have heard
great out cries for and against the
policing of science our response as an
academic community must not be one of
knee-jerk defensiveness against our
critics rather we must engage seriously
with our thoughtful critics as well as
our colleagues as we develop ways to
continuously foster academic integrity
to deal forthrightly and fairly with
problems when they arise if we are not
able to do so we can be sure that others
will be only too glad to do it for us
public confidence in our universities
must be fully restored our social
compact must be re-established but in
the discourse required to do so we must
avoid the trap of justifying all that we
do on utilitarian grounds clearly we
have been great contributors to the
nation's economy and this must continue
to be a cardinal element of mi t--'s
mission but we must take care not to
over emphasize these contributions as
the justification for investing in
universities if we overuse such
arguments we might unwittingly endanger
our traditions of intellectual
excellence innovation integrity openness
worldwide service deep scholarship and
independent criticism ultimately our
contributions to social progress
well-being rests on our ability to steer
our own course with imagination and
intellectual daring
what then is my vision of MIT a decade
hence MIT will be a preeminent
wellspring of scientific knowledge and
technological innovation MIT will foster
the pursuits of individual scholars
whose work so often leads to truly
fundamental discoveries we will be known
for our ability to establish new and
effective methods for analyzing complex
and pervasive issues facing the nation
in the world in an invigorated
partnership with industry the government
and other educational institutions we
will contribute profoundly to their
solution mit will be known for educating
for educating engineers who combined the
spirit of innovation and invention with
the passion for the highest quality and
efficiency and design and production MIT
will better reflect in our students our
faculty and our staff the changing face
of America we will find ways to instill
the excitement and romance of Science
and Mathematics into new generations of
young people MIT will spearhead efforts
to rekindle our nation's belief and the
importance of scientific research and
education we will have found renewed
commitment to the deepest values of the
Academy MIT will stand for integrity and
all that it does
mit will serve our nation well but also
will be of and for the greater world
community above all the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology will be a place
to which the brightest young men and
women will come for their education they
will be able to attend MIT regardless of
their financial circumstances they will
be taught and counseled by dedicated
teachers who themselves define the
leading edge of human knowledge and
invention their education will be robust
deep in scientific content yet providing
the flexibility and learning
skills to serve them well and
ever-changing and expanding
circumstances they will be attuned to
the complexities of their world a world
that they will help to change through
that wonderful blend of undergraduate
education graduate education research
and creative activity that is MIT our
students will be enriched and they in
turn will enrich the Institute men set
manas with mind and hand we set forth
our promise will be secured by the
collective energies and wisdom of those
who are drawn to this great magnet for
intellect and creativity together we
will give shape to the future the future
of MIT our nation and our world thank
you very much
[Applause]
before we adjourn I would like to invite
all of you to the MIT community
reception which will be held immediately
following this ceremony on the Kresge
oval that's on the West Campus across
Massachusetts Avenue from the main
entrance the audience is requested to
remain seated until the completion of
the procession the members of the
inaugural procession will now please
rise I now declare this meeting
adjourned
and let this great all Institute go
forward under the leadership of its new
president
[Applause]
[Music]
you